non ti farà più a lui ti prego
che schifo Qualcuno ti ha dimenticato di
tirare l'acqua in bagno Però giuro
Voglio che voi siate qua per sempre
Benvenuti sul nostro Stories oggi
nuovissimo gioco pauroso Infatti se
vedete questa bambina di nome Amanda che
fate
Come si prende tipo ancora non vedo
l'ora che mi piace iniziamo subito
subito hahaha
subito prendere una di queste macchine
prendiamo quella quella rossa Andiamo
con la macchina rossa A presto presto sì
Sì sì Sì
eccoci e ora aspettiamo che parta sembra
tutto così tranquillo dice pronto pronto
pronto a 0 di 10 richiede 5 vittorie Ah
ok allora non possiamo andare
questa qui ok Pronto Siamo in due Inizia
fra poco praticamente Questo è un gioco
pauroso Non sappiamo quasi niente ma
sappiamo solo che è Amanda il nome della
bambina cattiva non sappiamo cosa
succederà ci farà Ah ah ah Ma voi non mi
piace se volete vedere altri giochi
paurose se questo video raggiunge 5.000
mi piace faremo altri giochi paurosi
Amanda l'avventuriero sembra tipo oh oh
tutto così carino sembra un cartone
animato semplice
un giocatore si deve caricare si mette
sotto carica
Ecco Questa dovrebbe essere la casa di
Amanda Ehi ragazzi benvenuti nella mia
casa allora non è a casa di manda' uno
sguardo intorno e così comoda è
tranquilla tranquilla
per esplorare vuol dire che bisogna
trovare subito un indizio una via di
corredo di aver capito che cosa che
quando ci addormenteremo arriverà la
moda Sì in genere di notte al buio
arrivano in questo non ci Cattivissimo
ci sono solo due stanze Ho un'idea dice
Jake che idea andiamo a mangiare no
andiamo a giocare là fuori Ok andiamo a
giocare Andiamo
allora
Ok io vado sullo scivolo sembra tutto
così tranquillo
ci abbiamo tre Sei riuscito dall'altra
parte ma io com'è che non scivolo sullo
scivolo
dai via darmi una spinta fino
sembra tutto super tranquillo Ehi
bambini e ora di cena Venite dentro sì
ah ah ah ah ah
ah la mamma di Jake ci sta chiamando
Quindi dobbiamo rientrare Ma quando
arriverà questa Amanda Eh boh nel
frattempo mangiamo pizza digerita Hahaha
Eh pure tu intanto c'hai fame eh eh
Allora oh Dammi la verità
mangiamo dice Ok dammi sta pizza C'è
solo una pizza per noi che siamo in 10
mangia pizza dice obiettivo mangia pizza
pizza ok mangiata pure io sono una fetta
di pizza per 10 persone a squadre DJ che
è una tirchia
Ok ragazzi è diventato buio andare a
dormire Sono sicura che adesso arriva
mamma
possiamo guardare Amazon
che in realtà è una bambina cattiva
quindi No no grazie vediamo giù alla tv
Ah siete tutti giù io ero su Quindi
andate a letto ok Quindi 30 minuti di
Amanda l'avventuriero e poi andiamo a
letto Grazie mamma ora scopriremo che
cosa nasconde questa domanda non mi
ricordo dove ho messo il Davide cassetta
ma le video
Potete aiutarmi a cercarla e quindi
obiettivo trova episodio 1 Jake è colpa
tua che usi ancora la videocassettata di
comprare i DVD adesso oppure sul Cloud
direttamente dai
cerchiamo questa cassetta dove sarà la
gazzetta l'hai trovata Dai chi l'ha
trovata abbiamo guarda guardiamola
Perfetto Va bene io mi siedo qua nel
divano
Inserisci la cassetta Ok ecco manda
l'avventuriera Ma la cassetta era tipo
una cassetta tipo una cassetta di frutta
Ehi ciao a tutti Io sono Amanda Ma chi
Ah ma perché Amanda cioè un'amica
travestita da pecorella dobbiamo trovare
le verdure per nonna Ah quella è la
nonna Ah
pensavo che alla nonna non piacessero le
verdure No non è la nonna è lana la
pecora ah ah ah
non fa male provare qualcosa di nuovo
potete inventare al negozio
finora non sembra cattiva questa banda
sembra una ragazza normalissima Trova un
negozio di alimenti non farti colpire da
un'auto facile credo che questo sia uno
di quei giochi che si dispiace che devi
pagare Io robot Oh no no no no no oh oh
aspetta aspetta
piano a spiaccicato qualcuno lui
poverino
corri corri corri corri ok Stiamo quasi
presto andiamo a cercare le verdure Eh
io ho detto sì certo che te le troveremo
ma non me li fa prendere questo Queste
sono delle zucche in questo negozio ci
sono delle palline ho trovato una carota
aspetta prendi la carota ok Ho preso una
carota Ah sono nascoste le verdure Ok
un'altra carota e dice di andare a
quindi basta così ma come già No ne devi
trovare otto vedi otto
Ah forse devo lasciare la carota Ok l'ho
lasciata lì ah ah E poi cerchiamo di
capire presto Sbrigati prima che scade
il tempo come si fa a lasciarla non ho
capito Ah l'ho lasciata okay
Che cos'è questa
anche altre verdure lo sai non è andata
Ecco un'altra carota quindi ne abbiamo
sette di otto ne manca solo una ma come
una Io ho trovato due eh eh però lui mi
richiede solo 8 ok Andiamo
adesso io questa carota e ci siamo
fatto yeah bene Avete trovato le verdure
tutti gli ortaggi andiamoli a darle a
nonna ok
prendiamo la videocassetta per
l'episodio 2 ok come sarà
trova l'episodio 2 ok Ma perché finora
non c'è proprio niente di pauroso tranne
gli occhi di Jake
ma può essere nel microonde Secondo te
la cassetta
Non credo che sia così intelligente da
mettere Ragazze dentro al microonde
forse qua nella libreria però Jake fermo
lì e non fa niente Dobbiamo cercare noi
per lui non è giusto
[Musica]
mi sono dimenticato
Jake Vai Insomma hai trovato la cassetta
no sto cercando dal cibo vero
c'è ancora della pizza però qui ehm qua
non c'è niente
uffa sarà questa cassetta Ok al piano di
sopra non ho trovato niente può essere
in frigo Secondo te
non credo ma non me lo fa neanche aprire
il frigo però
Ma insomma altri giocatori Aiutateci a
trovarla no questa è la mamma di Jake
Quindi lei non la trova forse forse l'ho
trovata dove era proprio qui vicino in
cucina
l'ho trovata L'ho trovata Bravo Era
proprio qui nella lavanderina
bravissima Ok adesso ok la inserisco la
vediamo se adesso iniziamo le cose
paurose vediamo
Ok inserita
adesso Ecco di nuovo la pecora Ehi
Sbrigatevi Andate via andate via finché
potete Ok
C'è qualcosa che non va tutto tutto e
Amanda oggi Prendiamo della carne per la
nonna Ho paura che la carne avrà la
nonna saremo noi potete trovare anche
questo si ferme ok
la nonna ci vuole
vaccinare dobbiamo andare da questa
parte
penso che dobbiamo stare attenti alle
macchine anche qui attenta Non ti far
spiare via via
l'hai fatta No si è schiacciato ma non
sono morta Non so come mai
piano piano piano piano via
Ok
Credo sia questo blu il negozio ti
aspetta Ok
entriamo siamo nel negozio Ehi signor
macellaio
Potete dirgli cosa vogliamo che ha detto
che volevo vedere
abbiamo votato siamo rimasti solo in tre
a giocare quindi vuol dire che un
giocatore è stato fatto a fette ho
sfracellato sotto le macchine
[Musica]
Ehi Briga attentato aiuto potrebbe
essere pericoloso
sta arrivando dice il macellaio Okay
è stato fatto a fette andiamo a
consegnarlo alla nonna dice
Ehi è quasi l'ora di andare a dormire
presto troviamo l'episodio 3 ma questo
lo dice La madre ma hai appena detto che
dovevamo andare a dormire perché era
solo 30 minuti forse questo è l'ultimo
episodio Oh interessante
da cercare l'episodio 3 allora Dove
potrà essere bisogno 3 Ma Jake perché
oggi direttamente dove l'hai nascoste
queste cassette Uffa vediamo nell'altra
stanza ti consiglio di non entrare in
bagno Ah ok Ecco l'ho trovata Dov'è vera
sul bagno guarda Non ci puoi credere
Guardala Vieni vieni guarda guarda
è proprio sul bagno Ecco perché non ha
tirato la gamba così riusciremo a
trovare la sua sorpresina prendendo una
cassetta
Jake è troppo cattivo Ok andiamo a
guardare il terzo episodio E ora le cose
si fanno interessanti Ok terzo episodio
via Ciao a tutti Guardate la faccia di
Amanda
[Musica]
Benvenuti al terzo episodio ok
potete indovinare cosa faremo No non lo
voglio sapere
[Musica]
scappate è cattiva dice la pecora perché
gli hai detto di venire qua eh
ah ah è caduto per terra ci sta
inseguendo Non ti far prendere così
dobbiamo andare Non lo so dove entrano
in questa casa No entriamo qui nel
tunnel nel tunnel No non si può andare
Oddio aiuto
[Musica]
ehm Aiuto aiuto Dov'è Boh
poverina quella giocatrice
presto Venite qua dov'è la pecora
o no Dov'è dov'è Beh trova vuli quindi
dobbiamo trovare la pecora presto sono
lei che si potrà salvare
provo a entrare nella casetta
prova dietro la casa forse
[Musica]
No non fa entrare nella casa ti avevo
detto dietro la casa perché Ecco ho
paura e dovrebbe essere più sicuro qua
entrate dove forse qua dentro ma non fai
entrare Ecco aspetta Ok ansia
Ok Dove siamo siamo pronti
non nascondiglio non sono sicura ma non
tornerò indietro andiamo perché io ho la
gonna nella faccia Boh
segui Jake
Ehi sei un po' lento Jake Secondo me
Jake c'entra qualcosa
Non ho paura Ma questi sotto casa
c'hanno la miniera Guarda quanto stiamo
scendendo giù vuol dire che stanno
nascondendo qualcosa tutti gli altri
giocatori Infatti affetto dalla nonna
assolutamente
dici che è una trappola
[Musica]
Beh non abbiamo altra scelta non
possiamo tornare fuori da Amanda Ok
allora qui che cosa c'hanno
delle mazze non sono sicura di questo
prendi una mazza così possiamo
proteggerci
Come funziona prepariamoci a combattere
e non colpire bene sembra ci sia una
caverna qui dobbiamo andare nella
caverna
andiamo potrebbe essere la via d'uscita
e andiamo dai sbrigati andiamo ok Sembra
che ci sono due strade che possiamo
prendere Oh no
una di queste potrebbe essere una
trappola la sapevo Ehi Jack Ho un'idea
perché non vai prima tu eh Eh
io prendo questa vediamo
ok Siamo caduti
ci siamo salvati anche lei
mi ha fatto questa meno piano meno male
abbiamo scelto questo ho un hobby
Sicuramente ci sarà il tempo quindi
Attento a non sfracellarsi e attento a
non far cadere il tempo Ok
dall'altro lato super concentrato va
bene
344 secondi in modo fighissimo dai
Attento a non cadere altrimenti non
credo che puoi ritornare nel gioco va
bene ci provo e sarò da sola
piano piano prendi piano e lo rinforza
eh
Ok Ci siamo quasi piano piano l'ultimo
e ora spero che questa sia riuscita
andiamo a me sembra troppo facile
sicuramente dovremmo affrontare Amanda
alla fine
Allora io tolgo questo dove credete
gigante voglio che voi siate qua per
sempre
Amanda però ti sembra di esagerare un
po' forse tornare a casa manda dice Jake
perché non volete restare Uh
perché sei cattiva
vi farò restare
Mamma mia mi sa che dobbiamo
dire che lancia pure il laser che ha
fatto
Rompi le catene
presto presto queste catene
sta sparando anche dei laser dei fulmini
presto devi andare a rompere queste
catene
delle cose rosse che bisogna stare
attenti ad aiutare ti devi spostare
quando vedi il cerchio rosso su di te
Ok Vitale sta facendo la rinascita con i
robot
Allora riprovo eh
Sei riuscita Attento alla lava sta
salendo no
No no
Dove dovevamo andare quindi bisogna
stare super attenti perché quando arriva
la lava bisogna andare su quei su quei
Ah Sta arrivando la lavastoviglie
è difficilissimo Infatti è rimasto
Vitale da solo dietro aiuto ma come si
fa è impossibile quindi come dicevo io
non sono neanche riuscita a prendere i
robot perché ehm cioè il limite di tempo
non sono fatto di tempo e sono Boh io
sto cercando di dirlo scappare Vediamo
se Vitale ce la farò ma anche lui sta
finendo Uh è difficile farlo da sola Sì
infatti ci vorrebbero altri giocatori
bravissimo bravissimo
ma la lava non potrebbe sciogliere anche
quelle catene E infatti
C'è mancato poco Dai forse ce la
facciamo ma solo uno basta li devo fare
tutti e quattro
Ah salendo No no oh oh banana l'hanno
fatto difficilissimo questo gioco questo
Ma mmm mi Aiuto Manca poco vai solo però
eh
ancora colpo qui
hai levato il primo coso
e come farò Adesso anche per gli altri
riuscirò qui a
salire quando sale la lava non lo so
spero che ci siano Sì ci sono gli altri
lì dietro Vedi vai vai vai quello più
alto Ok dai dai stai andando benissimo
tutti e quattro gli altri Devi stare
super attenti
Eh bravo bravo bravo dobbiamo passare da
questa parte adesso
Oh oh oh oh no no no no no no no no no
no Vai sopra vai sopra vai sopra no
Ok ragazzi Questa è la nostra ultima
possibilità Qual è l'ultima che dobbiamo
fare qui
da questa parte credo di sì quindi altre
quattro catene Sarà difficilissimo
sta già salendo la lava no Ora lei è
impegnata
ok
giusto
Claudio questa domanda basta energia
pure Sì ma quanto l'hanno fatto di
difficile
Questo è quello più alto è sempre
l'altro
è sempre alto
e basta basta colpirci lavanda vai vai
vai vai
e dopo di questo ne manca solo uno
scherzo dai possiamo farcela Speriamo
Ok
adesso potrebbe salire la lava quindi
attento a salire sopra
sta salendo la lava mi sa eh
[Musica]
ok ragazzi Noi siamo delle schiappe
siamo morti Cioè più che altro siamo
morti un sacco di volte Ecco cosa
sarebbe dovuto succedere a questo
giocatore Bravo cosa sarebbe dovuto
succedere almeno finalmente vediamo la
fine
no gridando
Mi dispiace ci dice Amanda guarda con
tutti i robot
mi piace di più a me ce l'abbiamo fatta
Ehi Eccovi ragazzi dice la pecora Per
fortuna è ancora viva Comunque so che
c'è una via qua fuori ok
vi fidate di me piace
credo Diciamo che sei amica di Amanda
quindi
gli ha detto no ha cliccato No io avrei
cliccato di sì forse
voi non mi credete Cioè non vi fidate di
me
ma io sto provando ad aiutarvi allora
anche la pecora si arrabbia
[Risate]
L'hai uccisa Forse si sta arrabbiando
adesso Google
10 volte Ora non ho nessuno
ma vieni con noi no sì aspetta un'ultima
idea voi potete restare qua con me oh no
proprio come la manda Amanda ho detto
rimanete qui con me per sempre proprio
come ha detto Amanda
[Musica]
finale
Cioè questo era il finale brutto no no
guarda guarda ho ricominciato e forse
ora prova preme di sì e quindi ci sarà
il finale buono Ecco ora premuto sì
Vediamo cosa succede
buona scelta Mmm usciamo qua prima che
manda vi trovi alle non sa che Amanda è
sprofondato andare nella lava non vi
preoccupate non farà male cosa
non mi dire che ci vuole buttare nella
lava c'è un portale lì
sta assorbendo il personaggio nel
portale Ops Ehi ragazzi allora di andare
a dormire la mamma di Jake Praticamente
siamo stati tipo risucchiati nel portale
della parte 3 dei video di Amanda
Grazie
non credo di riuscire a dormire lavoro
che è successo
anche se noi non siamo riusciti perché
siamo morti 20 volte almeno abbiamo
battuto l'avventura insieme a voi
abbiamo scoperto cosa succede dopo
lasciate un bel mi piace Ora vi lasciamo
Qua quattro caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video eh Buona
visione Ciao